welcome back to las vegas now your
insurance agency is back to tell you
what you need to know as the medicare
enrollment period comes to an end
take a look
[Music]
things are going well this enrollment
season i think that
we've reassured a lot of people of the
plans they have
we're reassuring them of what needs to
be done or what changes need to be made
if it's going to improve their situation
and so with technology
is what's been going on with covet we've
all found new ways to
help people and so before it was always
face time
but we have the ability to do through
our virtual office a broker box where we
can do virtual office visits
we can do it over the telephone verified
benefits and then also
send them everything through an email to
where they do an e-signature if you will
and which is electronic signature so we
have
ways to serve everyone wherever they
need to be met however that needs to be
done
and so this year is filled with a lot of
changes
new carriers in the market and we're
here to
help guide them to those best plans that
fits their needs
so when it comes to serving you
we serve regardless if we're making a
sale believe it or not
there are times when you come to us and
you realize
in your situation you need to be
enrolled in medicaid
we help you enroll in medicaid sometimes
you're above medicaid and we help get
the subsidies there we have subsidies
that are available in nevada
that will not only offset your premium
but also buy your deductible down
we have plans with zero deductibles if
you qualify
but we can help with that help you
assess that and that's our job
when it comes to individual family plans
right now there's a lot of
uneasiness on what to do now i don't
know if i'm going to get my job back
i'm still kind of furloughed i'm maybe
working one or two days a week
or i'm still on unemployment
unemployment's supposed to run out
and when we go in help people get
coverage or individual family coverage
to the marketplace we have to use their
income projected income for 2021.
so they get nervous and they're
reluctant what do i do reality is they
need to call us
we have special forms that we use that
are for consideration
to help them guide them through what we
need to do to help them get them covered
so it starts
january 1st remember
we can't predict what 2021 is going to
look like
we could predict what's going to happen
in 2020 right so in 2021
we can always adjust income throughout
the year
but we can't make a decision to buy a
plan
when it's already passed open enrollment
please do not be afraid to call
we serve you first we're not going to
try to sell you we educate you
first it's always about educating you so
you can make an informed
intelligent decision we we have no
problem with you bringing family
we have no problem with trying to make
sure you understand what you're doing
so you feel confident and comfortable in
what you're doing
that's what we're about to make you make
the best decision for you
and your family for more information
call 702-425-5500 or visit
y i a lv.com and tomorrow
join them for their 10 a.m to 9 p.m
medicare
last chance enrollment event we'll be
right back